Hollywood had its biggest year ever in 2018
- despite streaming sites like Netflix and
Hulu staking a claim on its territory.
But thanks to this year's crop of amazing
films, that box office record might not last
for long.
Here are the best movies of 2019... so far.
If there were any concerns that writer/director
Jordan Peele's Academy Award-winning debut
Get Out was a fluke, they were quickly laid
to rest by Us.
In the film, a family is taunted by evil versions
of themselves… and it's highly unsettling
stuff.
"Who are you people?"
"It's us."
Critics were particularly stunned by Lupita
Nyong'o's performance.
The Lamplight Review noted that:
"Performances in genre pieces are often dismissed
and disregarded, but make no mistake: Nyong'o's
work in Us is some of the very best of her
career."
Critics were also impressed by Peele's deft
mixing of comedic elements with nerve-jangling
terror.
A review in Splice Today succinctly summed
up his achievement, claiming that
"Us combines masterful visuals with dense
storytelling, and a half-dozen instant-classic
sequences.
And it's scary as hell."
Right now, writer/director Nia DaCosta only
has a handful of credits to her name.
But thanks to Little Woods, her insanely self-assured
debut feature, that's about to change in a
hurry.
DaCosta wrote the screenplay for Little Woods;
a story about two troubled sisters.
One of them is a convicted drug runner who's
trying to get through her last few days of
probation.
Unfortunately, she's forced to return to the
drug trade after her mother dies, leaving
behind a hefty mortgage on the family home.
"I know you're selling again.
And I don't appreciate losing customers because
you decided to get back in the business."
By casting Tessa Thompson in the lead role
of Ollie, DaCosta nabbed one of the hottest
actresses working today.
Her performance was roundly praised, with
descriptors like "towering" and "riveting"
being par for the course.
But it's DaCosta's keen eye for small details
and sweeping, cinematic shots that really
had the critics singing her praises.
And she's just getting started, too.
In fact, she's all set to update the horror
classic Candyman for producer Jordan Peele.
And that should definitely be a sight to see.
There's been more written about Avengers:
Endgame than any other cinematic release in
recent memory.
But the fact that it's really good film is
often buried beneath the reams of press and
publicity.
Avengers: Endgame is brimming with jaw-dropping
action, a surprising amount of humor, and
the kind of emotional resonance that's sure
to captivate diehard fans and casual moviegoers
alike.
"You trust me?"
"I do."
Many critics pegged Avengers: Endgame as one
of the greatest acts of fan service ever committed
to film.
And while familiarity with the MCU is pretty
much required to make it a complete viewing
experience, the movie is even more impressive
for how well it works on its own terms.
Flick Filosopher enthused that
"[Avengers: Endgame is] a miraculous blend
of grief and humor.
Big, bold, brash, then sneakily meta."
Siftpop stated in no uncertain terms just
how much the film rocks, writing that:
"The word epic gets thrown around so much
that we've forgotten what it actually means.
This movie is here to remind you."
Meanwhile, the London Evening Standard apparently
couldn't say enough good things about the
film, writing that:
"The only complaint about Avengers: Endgame
is that it raises the bar so high that there
may well never be a superhero movie to match
it."
The John Wick series has never aspired to
be high art… but it just might be the purest
adrenaline delivery device in the history
of modern cinema.
Three films in, director Chad Stahelski and
star Keanu Reeves have really perfected the
formula.
John Wick: Chapter 3 - Parabellum gives diehard
action fans exactly what they came for - and
then some.
It's easy to see why Reeves' beleaguered hitman
is swiftly becoming an icon.
Let it suffice to say, the actor's committed
performance and Stahleski's sharp direction
had critics applauding the third entry in
the series.
Scotland's The Herald wrote:
"[Reeves] has charisma to burn.
By the time two hours are up, Wick is once
again living up to the Latin in the title,
desiring peace but preparing for war.
Fetch, John, Fetch."
In its own highly positive review, The Movie
Blog said
"John Wick 3 is a buffet of action that only
leaves you wanting more."
Flickering Myth was just as enthusiastic,
writing that:
"Where most franchises begin to stumble around
movie three, John Wick: Chapter 3 is the best
in this highly entertaining series."
The rom-com genre isn't exactly known for
its inventive and intriguing storylines.
But thanks to a whip-smart screenplay, Long
Shot is something truly special.
Seth Rogen stars as Fred Flarsky, a journalist
who ends up reconnecting with his childhood
babysitter Charlotte Field, played by Charlize
Theron.
It turns out Charlotte's become a highly powerful
political figure.
In fact, she's gearing up for a presidential
run.
When Charlotte impulsively appoints Fred to
be her speechwriter, events take a decidedly
romantic turn.
The chemistry between the two leads is really
something to marvel at, as you can see for
yourself:
"You asked."
"No, hey, I've hooked up with my fair share
of world leaders too."
Critics absolutely loved the film, with the
Daily Herald gushing:
"What are the odds that this zany rom-com
would turn out to be the funniest crowd-pleaser
of 2019 so far?"
The Mail on Sunday was equally effusive in
its praise:
"This is surely one of the most welcome surprises
of the cinematic year, with Jonathan Levine's
enjoyable film showing that unorthodox casting
combinations can work and that there is still
life in the romantic comedy.
Hurrah!"
An updated, family-friendly take on the King
Arthur legend, The Kid Who Would Be King had
a lot of things going for it right out of
the gate.
It's the second directorial effort from Joe
Cornish, who helmed the excellent sci-fi comedy
Attack the Block and co-wrote the original
script for Marvel's Ant-Man.
The film's casting is pure genius, with Sir
Patrick Stewart as the wizard Merlin and Rebecca
Ferguson as the evil enchantress Morgana.
Louis Ashborne Serkis stars as a British schoolboy
who stumbles upon the mythical sword Excalibur
and must embrace his identity as a leader.
Unfortunately, The Kid Who Would Be King was
a commercial failure for Fox - but it certainly
scored big with critics.
The Guardian said,
"[The film is] sentimental in all the right
places, and impossible to dislike."
Meanwhile, One Room With A View praised Cornish's
direction, claiming that
"[He delivers a] sword-and-sorcery adventure
with the intelligence and sensitivity that
kids' films deserve, but do not always receive."
Hopefully, the film's poor box-office performance
won't diminish Cornish's future prospects.
He's got talent to spare, and he's proven
to be highly skilled at juggling comedic and
dramatic elements in the service of his wholly
unique visions.
In order to succeed, Captain Marvel had to
give us a compelling origin story and set
the scene for Avengers: Endgame.
Indie filmmakers Anna Boden and Ryan Fleck
rose to the occasion brilliantly, and their
first big-budget tentpole movie is supremely
entertaining.
Thanks to an incredible script - and a particularly
brilliant lead performance from Oscar winner
Brie Larson, the film is an absolute triumph.
Critics commended Larson for bringing a strong
sense of fun and swagger to the role of Carol
Danvers, and many reviewers praised the onscreen
chemistry between Larson and Samuel L. Jackson,
who portrays a digitally de-aged Nick Fury.
"How long you plan to be in town?"
"Oh, I'll be out of your hair as soon as I
track down the Skrulls that are infiltrating
your planet."
"Skrulls?"
Reviewers also loved Ben Mendelsohn's performance
as the Skrull warrior Talos.
The Maine Edge absolutely loved the film,
noting how
"Captain Marvel could have floundered under
the storytelling load it was asked to shoulder,
but instead manages to (mostly) soar, giving
us a fun and engaging narrative, some decent
gags and some solid action set pieces (along
with a killer ‘90s soundtrack)."
Shazam! just might be the warmest, friendliest,
goofiest superhero film ever.
Zachary Levi completely sells the notion of
a 14-year-old inhabiting a superhero's body,
bringing a wide-eyed wonder to the role.
"Your phone's charged, your phone's charged,
and your phone’s charged…well you think
you could do better?"
"The hell…?"
Critics were quick to embrace the film, with
The Wall Street Journal writing that
"What Shazam! lacks most obviously is gravitas.
And grimness.
Also bleakness, darkness and relentless self-seriousness.
In other words, it's terrific fun."
Other critics noted that director David F.
Sandberg masterfully juggled the film's humorous,
emotional, and action-packed sequences.
And some reviewers were excited about what
this could mean for the future of the DC Extended
Universe, with Salon boldly proclaiming that:
"[Shazam! is] a sign that it is at last ready
to compete with Marvel."
2014's The Lego Movie was a surprise hit,
and definitely one of the best animated films
of the year.
In fact, if we're being honest, it's better
than any film based on building-block toys
has any right to be.
This year's The Lego Movie 2: The Second Part
saw the return of the first film's stellar
voice cast, including Chris Pratt, Elizabeth
Banks, Will Ferrell, and Will Arnett.
It also added talent like Tiffany Haddish
and Jason Momoa, who reprised his role as
Aquaman from last year's live-action blockbuster.
Film Inquiry had nothing but good things to
say about Lego Movie 2: The Second Part, writing
that:
"It's a rare film; a perfectly crafted sequel
that expands on the world and mythology of
its predecessor, but stands firmly on its
own little Lego-legs."
Dreamworks' How to Train Your Dragon franchise
has garnered the kind of critical praise and
box-office receipts normally reserved for
Pixar's offerings.
And there's a very good reason for that.
Each of the films are technically accomplished
and imbued with a depth of storytelling and
emotion that's highly uncommon in kids' animated
features.
The 2010 original and 2014's How to Train
Your Dragon 2 raked in over a billion dollars
worldwide.
It took five long years for trilogy capper
The Hidden World to finally arrive, and guess
what?
The wait was well worth it, because the film
is really good.
Critics thought so, too.
Laramie Movie Scope wrote that
"[It's a] nice story, combined with marvelous
animation, which has only gotten more sophisticated
and effective over the years, thanks to advances
in technology."
Meanwhile, The New York Post proclaimed that
"The movie could easily be called How To End
Your Trilogy."
Over the years, animation house Laika Studios
has released quite a few films - and they've
all been highly unique.
There's the 2009 hit Coraline, 2012's ParaNorman,
and the well-received 2016 fantasy film Kubo
and the Two Strings.
For this year's Missing Link, the studio recruited
ParaNorman director Chris Butler and a talented
voice cast featuring Hugh Jackman, Zack Galifianakis,
and Zoe Saldana.
It's the story of a Bigfoot-like creature
who enlists famous explorers to lead him on
a quest to find his relatives.
"Can you take me there?"
"I give you my word."
The action-packed narrative and sweet humor
really won over reviewers... but the eye-popping
stop-motion animation is undoubtedly Missing
Link's ace in the hole.
The website Rave claimed
"Missing Link continues to prove not only
Laika's visual mastery, but also the studio's
commitment to telling emotionally resonant
stories."
Consequence of Sound was equally generous
in its praise:
"As with so many Laika films, you'll come
for the breathtaking animation, and you'll
leave both enchanted and surprised by the
big, beating heart beneath it."
Even the less effusive reviews couldn't help
but gush over the film's visual style.
Although The Washington Post claimed the film
was "missing something," it also assured readers
that
"[The movie] is visually stunning, with well-realized
characters and humor that really does work."
Sadly, the film's lackluster box office performance
might not be enough to keep the financially
troubled animation house afloat.
But as you can see, the film is absolutely
beautiful to look at, and we strongly recommend
watching the film if you haven't already.
"A rope would be better."
"I don't know.
Three more of them and we could build a ramp."
The Toy Story series offered up three near-perfect
animated films in the space of fifteen years,
and after a flawless capper in Toy Story 3
and a nine-year gap, fans could be forgiven
for being a bit wary of Toy Story 4.
"So long, partner."
But Pixar did it once again, fielding a fourth
entry in the saga of Woody, Buzz, and the
gang that's every bit as heartfelt, lovingly
animated, and hilarious as its predecessors.
Matthew Norman of the London Evening Standard
wrote,
"Toy Story 4 is so good it's criminal.
The legislation it flouts is the law of diminishing
returns which governs movies with numbers
after their names."
The film's accolades were many, and covered
every aspect of its production, from the animation
to the story to its treatment of its new characters.
NBC News' Ani Bundel wrote,
"Everyone gets time to tell their story, whether
it's Duke Caboom or Buzz Lightyear."
But perhaps the highest praise, delivered
by Reno News & Review's Bob Grimm:
"Is it the last one?
Oh, come on.
Just keep making these movies forever."
2019 has been something special for Marvel
Studios, with three critically acclaimed,
billion-dollar-plus grossing hits - an unprecedented
feat to bring a close to the three-phase Infinity
Saga.
The saga concluded with the sweet, action-packed
coda Spider-Man: Far from Home, the first
live-action Spidey vehicle to ever break a
billion at the global box office.
Critics were taken with how the film played
with the conventions of its genre, continually
upending audience expectations - especially
with respect to its alleged secondary "hero,"
the devious Mysterio played by Jake Gyllenhaal,
whose performance garnered widespread praise,
as did star Tom Holland.
The Spider-Man series remains a favorite among
Marvel fans, thanks to director Jon Watts'
distinctive John Hughes-like tone.
For all its butt-kicking spectacle, many critics
praised it as simply a delightful coming-of-age
comedy which just happened to also feature
some of the most jaw-dropping post-credits
scenes the MCU has yet offered.
Producer Sam Raimi and director Alexandre
Aja have a highly admirable horror pedigree,
and Crawl sported a unique premise: trapped
in her father's home during a massive hurricane
with flood waters on the rise, a woman gets
some unexpected company in the form of some
hungry alligators.
The flick milks this premise for all it's
worth, and critics generally agreed that the
result was a white-knuckle fright-fest rich
with tension and chills.
Lead Kaya Scoledario was praised for her energetic
performance, helping to whisk the film along
from one terrifying set piece to the next.
As many of the flick's champions noted, it's
tough to go wrong in the hands of skilled
filmmakers with all of these ingredients at
their disposal.
The Movie Blog's Emmanuel Noisette wrote:
"When you combine a natural disaster, scary
predators, [and] confined spaces, all through
a personal human lens, you have a solid film
on your hands."
While the movie had its requisite share of
detractors, its defenders noted that Crawl
delivered exactly what it promised.
Pete Vonder Haar of Houston Press wrote:
"If you go into Crawl hoping to see a woman
improbably outswim large, pissed-off reptiles,
or watch ATM thieves get messily devoured,
you're in for one of the most enjoyable theatrical
experiences of the year."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.